here's how two-thirds of americans have
used their stimulus checks those 1400
stimulus checks that started hitting
mailboxes in march are proven valuable
to people overwhelmed by debt
a study from bill paying service daxo
finds that 62 percent of stimulus checks
are being used to pay bills
with a significant portion of the
earmark for crediting uh
credit card debt since the start of the
pandemic says doc so 42
americans have skipped paying at least
one bill interesting 42 percent of
americans have skipped paying one bill
the doctor number fall in line with the
data from u.s census bureau household
pulse
survey in march a study from that group
show the majority of stimulus checks
recipients planned
to use the money on food and utilities
as household budgets
remain stretched during the pandemic a
study of 110 million people
who reported receiving stimulus checks
taken between february 14
february 17 and march 4 showed debt
reduction
and household expenses as the top
priorities
adam thoughts yeah i mean this is
there's a lot to unpack here i actually
love this story
so um i think the number is 90 of
americans are receiving some form of
stimulus
i didn't get a check though you know
well if you make over 75 000 which i
assume you do pat i know you've had some
up and down years but
uh if you make under 75 000 or less
you'll get
1400 i get phases out i believe it 80
000 like if you make 78 000 as an
example you might get a check for like
800 bucks
but then it starts to phase out if
you're married you get a you make
if you have a household income if you're
married if you're under 150
000 you'll get uh the full 2 800 and if
you have dependents that are each
getting so
you know i went down to south beach and
i was interviewing a lot of people down
there what they did
phenomenal by the way thank you check it
out on valuetainment economics a great
amazing interview one girl
she i said oh how much you get 1400 she
goes no 4200 i go wow that's amazing
you're married kids dependents all that
i go how much did you spend to be here
4 200 oh my god what are you doing
what are you doing so there's a lot of
those kind of interviews down there in
south beach but
here's why i love this story so much
two-thirds of americans
have used their stimulus check to pay
off debt so
you know i have my six principles of
wealth philosophy
and number one is having a game plan for
your money which is a budget what's your
income what your expenses and all that
and then i say number two is before you
can win the money game
don't lose and what's losing losing is
debt
so debt is your money going backwards so
the average interest rate on a credit
card is 16
in america the average how the average
credit card
amount in debt is six thousand dollars
so if you're getting fourteen hundred
dollar check or even a forty two hundred
dollar dollar check
the best return on your investment might
be to pay down that sixteen percent
interest rate
or in some cases twenty four twenty five
percent interest rate or if you have a
payday loan it might be four or five
hundred percent
get the f out of debt before you can
start saving and start investing
i know there's other stories out there
that tom i'll hand it over to you
people that don't have debt are actually
pumping their money right into the stock
market into
robin hood and becoming investors so
here's my last point eighty percent of
americans
have debt eighty percent of americans
have some form of debt
only fifty five percent of americans are
actually investing in the stock market
so your goal should be to have a game
plan for your money get that f
out of debt start to save that money so
you can start investing
so i applaud these people that actually
paid off their debt with that
good for them good for them tom what do
you think well i think americans are
behaving
responsibly and i think it's great you
basically got them paying for
they're saying hey we're spending this
on core living
you know household expenses and food
core living and i'm also knocking down
some debt that i had i think that's a
very responsible thing to do
now does that bring back main street
does that make bring back restaurants
and
and entertainment in in towns and cities
no
not yet but i think for the average
american for inside the household i
think it's very good but is it bringing
back
you know the life to the cities and
never mind spring break
never mind what's going on you know
south texas or south florida
what i'm talking about is casual
entertainment in any town usa
you know going out to do something going
out to dinner restaurants are just now
open
so that's not getting a lot of support
but i think it's really good news that
americans are doing this
because i think it makes the you know
you don't want all the americans
stressed
and i think this is a very good thing
flip side you know the single americans
you met one i don't think that was the
terribly responsible answer she gave
but also you had millennials that were
single saying hey thanks for the
stimulus i'm going to go buy some crypto
and i have my coinbase account and i'm
going to go
buy some nfts you know some interesting
things some music clips that i like
i'm like uh that's you know that's a
great story for
national media because it's like the oh
my gosh kind of angle to the head wait
so you're saying not a good idea to take
your stimulus to go buy nfts
no i don't think so if somebody said hey
i put it in my you know i maxed out my
annual limit for my 401k and bought a
you know some more stock
and some mutual or something yeah okay
great that's that's a savings plan
but when you hear like the hey i'm just
going to gamble with it if i lose it
they're losing
so what do you think about nfts what do
you think about nft i think
look i i think this is a new collectible
that's here to stay but i'm i'm saying
that those millennials that took the
stimulus check and the first thing they
did
was basically gamble you know higher
risk
i don't think that's too smart but i
love what american families and
households did with the stimulus
people trying to get rich quick is what
you're saying well so what did you do
with your stimulus check
what's the stimulus you're so funny so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye